this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 12. with Echo Charles and me
Jocko willink good evening Echo good
evening also joining us tonight is Daryl
Cooper good evening Daryl happy to be
here
[Music]
everyone is insane
everyone is insane I have been thinking
about this lately the clinical
definition of insanity is
a mental illness of such a severe nature
that a person cannot distinguish fantasy
from reality cannot conduct their
Affairs due to psychosis or is subject
to uncontrollable impulsive behavior
that's the clinical definition of
insanity and I was reading about someone
recently
that was clinically insane
and then I was also reading a book about
a particular General during a war
who
he wasn't maybe clinically insane to
this level but his actions started to
make me think that he actually does have
some level of insanity because he
couldn't distinguish fantasy from
reality
so let's break this down a little bit
because I think I'm right what I think
is everyone's insane on some level so
first of all think about this the first
section there cannot distinguish fantasy
from reality
cannot distinguish fantasy from reality
okay so you get the stereotypical person
on the street that's yelling at a
telephone pole or whatever right they're
delusional they don't think other people
can see what they're doing
they think they're more capable than
they are you know that's that's kind of
the thing that clued me in off this
whole idea was this this particular
military General who was doing things
who didn't understand the reality of the
situation that he was in
just didn't understand it
so cannot distinguish fantasy from
reality that's part one part two cannot
conduct Affairs due to psychosis
what does that mean that means you're
not doing what you're supposed to be
doing you're not doing what you're
supposed to be doing
is there anyone listening to this Echo
Charles is there any day that you don't
exactly do what you're supposed to be
doing
does that ever happen you don't conduct
your Affairs the way you're supposed to
does that ever happen to you Daryl has
there ever been a day where you didn't
quite conduct the Affairs you were
supposed to do
well no no comment
okay subject to uncontrollable impulsive
behavior
uh do we even need to ask that question
right what about a donut
who had what about a piece of pizza what
about the anger what about the Smashing
of the whatever the the the kitchen
counter
uncontrollable impulsive behavior
you can't stop yourself from doing that
thing at that moment
and here's the other part of this and
it's not part of the definition but I
looked it up and it is
it is part of insanity is that insane
people don't know that they're insane
they don't know that they're insane
they're not aware of it and this is
another thing reading about this
particular military leader
who didn't realize what was happening he
didn't see how obviously mistaken he was
with the moves that he was making
like anybody on the outside would look
and say oh yeah this guy is clearly
making a mistake after a steak after
mistaken he didn't even realize it
didn't even realize it
and I think what happens is
what what that reminded me of
is that you're if you allow your head
to be an echo chamber for your own ideas
and your own thoughts and you only let
those thoughts rattle around in there
it's not gonna go well after a while it
ends up in a feedback loop was that a
positive feedback loop it's a positive
feedback loop it's feedback on a on an
amplifier
what does that mean it means we need to
be able to to detach
you know if you want to if you want to
distinguish fantasy from reality as a
human you got to detach from the
situation you're in if you want to
conduct Affairs regardless of how you're
feeling feeling you got to detach from
that if you want to overcome your
impulsive behaviors you've got to detach
you got to be able to take a step back
and detach it and by the way if you
don't do that
you don't realize your own psychosis
and this is similar from a leadership
perspective
if you're in an echo Chamber from a
leadership perspective if I'm the leader
and I'm coming up with ideas and Equity
Yes Man and Daryl's a Yes Man and
they're saying yeah both great ideas
that sounds great let's let's go ahead
and do that and no one questions me no
one pushes back we're caught in an echo
chamber of ideas and we're gonna fail
or chances are we're going to fail
so
we need to push back against ourselves
we need to question ourselves we need to
remember that the reality that we see
the reality that we actually see with
our own two eyes looks different from
other people's eyes
and you need to see if you can see what
they're seeing
you got to remember how things look
compared to what other people think they
look like
you got to remember that this idea of
being insane is something that we all
have a tendency to lean towards right we
we fail to identify or accept reality
it's one of the things I was talking
about with a bunch of businesses as as
covet kicked off
there were some people that were old and
go we were not gonna be locked down well
this this can't last oh fast forward six
months three months one year
people didn't accept the reality that
they were facing
we're just going to keep doing things it
doesn't work so so we have a tendency to
fail we fail to accept reality
we have a tendency to fail to do what
we're supposed to do we have the fa we
have a tendency to fail to conduct our
affairs
that's a tendency that we all have we
have a tendency to fail to control
impulsive behavior
these are things that everyone no one
can deny these things
and we don't even recognize and realize
what we're doing
foreign
so we don't even see that little bit of
psychosis setting in
we don't even see we don't even see that
little bit of psychosis setting in where
we are actually losing touch with
reality
our heads in an echo chamber
and the echo chamber
amplifies the lies
that we're telling ourselves it
amplifies our problems prevents
Solutions
so what we have to do is we have to
detach we have to ask questions we have
to listen
don't be a yes man to yourself
don't let that happen
don't let that happen
so Insanity what do you think Daryl am I
wrong
you're not wrong I think uh one of the
one of the most interesting things
interesting points to make to people in
this respect it's just like so many
other
qualities about people right take
courage for example you know some guys
who would run into a fire fight at the
drop of a hat to rescue their friend
but they just they don't have the
courage to stand up to their wife when
she's acting in a certain way or
something like that right
it's domain specific and insanity is
often domain specific it makes me think
of this uh this one woman I knew very
well I still know her um she's a she's a
great person
very intelligent Philosophy degree
master's degree you know graduated with
honors and philosophy
um she works in education she's been a
teacher vice principal and administrator
and she's the best bureaucrat that
anybody who has ever worked with her has
ever seen she's graded her job everybody
who knows her on she's she's brilliant
she's great she's just a normal person I
knew her very very well
and um she had a touch of paranoia that
she would she was an anxious person a
little bit paranoid now some people are
paranoid they think people are talking
about me behind my back when they're
really not interested that's a version
of it right but it escalates and one
time I was having a conversation with
her and
uh she said that you know I think at
work our secretary at work she brought
cookies for everybody at work
um the other day and or today rather and
she and the secretary uh had been having
some problems in my friend's eyes right
she would tell me the stories about the
problems they were having and I'm like I
don't know I I think there's a she could
have just meant that in a totally
innocent way I think maybe you're
blowing it out of proportion right but
the accumulation of those incidents led
her to think that this secretary had it
in for
and so she asked me
um she's like but I didn't eat any of
the cookies and then she looks me in the
eye I'm just hearing like okay the she
brought cookies and you didn't eat a
cookie and she looks me dead in the eyes
and says
do you think she was trying to poison me
and I said
listen to me very carefully I told her
very carefully or very seriously said no
I don't think she was trying to poison
you and do not repeat that to anybody
else
and because that's a crazy thing to
think I mean it was completely outside
the realm of possibility
and so she didn't repeat it to anybody
else and you know she even said like
yeah I know it's ridiculous I was just
joking and then she kind of just went
about it and nothing happened
but you think to yourself
what if I wasn't there to tell her that
and I was somebody she trusted who could
get through to her to like let her know
that that's not a good idea
um if she had gone to her supervisors
and said I think the secretary's trying
to poison me
and they would have been like excuse me
and they would have been I mean and the
whole thing could have been it could
have escalated into something where she
would have lost her job she may have
been committed to a son who knows I mean
it could have really gotten out of hand
and what happens a lot of times is then
maybe people think
um you know somebody like her would
think Well everybody's in on it they're
all on her side and that's how that
thing that kind of thing starts to to
escalate that's that positive feedback
loop you were talking about and
we do it on an individual level right
where you don't want to or you surround
yourself with Yes Men We Do It on the
group level you think of people like
Cults like Jim Jones where
you know descent is not allowed and so
there's this you happen to have a small
group with a dictator at the top and
there's nobody around who can actually
criticize them or tell me he's wrong
about anything so they just go off into
the stratosphere and you see it happen
with whole Nations where dissent is
banned in North Korea you can't
criticize anything that's going on and
so the people at the top if they're a
little unstable
you're Off to the Races you know
the the that's what had me thinking
about this that's what kind of the the
first thing I like sometimes I'm doing
something and I take a note in my this
whole idea came from me writing down
Echo Chambers
because I I was thinking about well we
we hear Echo Chambers a lot in the news
oh you're in an echo chamber on social
media right when you're on the gram for
instance Echo Charles when you're on the
gram
whatever you look at it feeds you more
of that food right it gives you more if
you're looking at liberal stuff
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground